i want to thank you for being here st
patrick's day of all days
this is incredible you've got the green
shoes i have of course
the lovely uh green sweater oh what you
got there
uh we got some whiskey uh to drink very
nice uh would you like some yes i would
all right great i will please ask your
questions as i
prepare well first of all we know each
other quite well
off screen we've had sex well if that's
what you want to call it
um but we are friends
we are friends even though i don't think
we like each other
oh we oh that's great wow
i'm already good i got my ice cream
thank you this will be mine
throw that uh one of your writers no no
this it's only on the floor
okay yeah no that'll be mine that'll be
right three day rule so uh
boy that our that went right yes we our
friends but don't like each other but
our wives
really make our wives get along here's
what i know about you
yes you never bring out a product unless
you're getting paid
i i know you you and and so i haven't
even
talked to you about this before what is
that maker's mark oh for god's sake
thank you it's the bourbon of choice in
my family
uh-huh yeah yeah it's the 101
uh i didn't get these glasses for free
which pisses me off can i ask you a
question i've never met anybody in
show business who is more
interested in in making a little
something on the side
with products that you genuinely love
but when you like a product
when you like a product joel mchale you
call the company and say i really like
your product
do you want me to do anything holding
your product and then can i have some
money and some of the product for free
true or false uh true and if they don't
respond
and don't want to then i'd like i never
liked it in the first place right
uh yeah so you contacted clearly maker's
mark
my uh hold on one second
oh that's the stuff wow that's very you
know what i'm not getting paid and i'll
say that's quite good happy st patrick's
day happy st patrick's day
going back yes i like getting stuff for
free because my
dad started that early on in my life
he he tried to procure things like if he
tried to return a pair of shoes and they
didn't have his size and he was like
well
you should just give me another pair for
free and often he got it
yeah my dad would also brag about these
things whenever he got some crazy deal
yep when i started getting stuff for
free my dad would always
he started going you're just bragging
yeah and then i'd be like yes
absolutely that's exactly what i'm doing
i'm bragging this is what you did you
taught you he taught you yes
i was like you should be proud all i got
i got them a free car at one point
and i feel i got look i'm not proud of
it but i was like
why not yeah they had to take it back
after 11 months
yeah that's fine that's not really
giving them a free car they were killed
in it
um
the important thing is you had a good
end to that story
uh i remember reading it were they in
the car when you returned it
yes he returned a charred card
that his parents were in uh and the
point
on that is gonna be huge when you
explore this story it's really dark
when i got there i was like this ford
focus doesn't work at all
i demand another one
you know um let's get back to your
voracious need
to make money commercialize what i
consider to be art
uh so many celebrities now post
ads on social media yeah get a little
extra
you know you know how much money you
could be making if you did that once in
a while money's never quite interested
me
it's why i live very humbly what are you
talking about you have a movie theater
in your house
that's not true what i did was that not
true kevin hart that is not
heart heart that is not a movie theater
you had quite a bit to drink the last
time you were over and you passed out
and then i drove you to a lowe's
and we watched a movie and then i told
you
yeah this is my movie theater and you
said this is incredible
and then you passed out again and i
drove you back to my house
you called me to help move you yeah andy
i was busy
andy dragged you he thought you were
dead for half an hour until
you started muttering i don't remember
any of this of course you don't you
drink a lot
you know what's nice we have a cardboard
audience and you're getting the same
number of laughs you get
when you're on the live show over the
years true there's been no
change in audience reaction well that's
why i'm having such a good time i can't
tell i can tell
and andy's awake it's so fun andy's
never seen a whole one of these shows
yeah you want some whiskey yeah sure but
later off camera
so i can really tell you how i feel oh
yeah okay